40 OUNCES OF
MALT LIQUOR
MAKE ME WANT TO
TELL YOU SOMETHIN'.
♪ SAID ROLLIN' AROUND
SITTIN' ON DUBS ♪
♪ COUNTIN' THE HOURS
HIGH ON SHRUBS ♪
♪ COOLIN' IN MY ESCALADE ♪
♪ MAN, I'M PAID
I GOT IT MADE ♪
♪ TAKE ME TO
YOUR SPECIAL PLACE ♪
♪ CLOSE YOUR EYES
SHOW ME YOUR FACE ♪
♪ I'M GONNA
PISS ON IT ♪
♪ HATERS WANNA HATE
LOVERS WANNA LOVE ♪
♪ I DON'T EVEN WANT
NONE OF THE ABOVE ♪
♪ I WANT TO PISS ON YOU
YES, I DO ♪
♪ I'LL PISS ON YOU
I'LL PEE ON YOU ♪
♪ SAID YOUR BODY
YOUR BODY ♪
♪ IS A PORT-A-POTTY ♪
♪ I'MA PEE
OUT KICK ♪
♪ I CAN USE KARATE
USE KARATE ♪
♪ I'MA PEE ON YOU ♪
♪ DRIP, DRIP, DRIP
PEE ON YOU ♪
♪ POUR ON YOU ♪
♪ PISS ON YOU
PISS ON YOU ♪
♪ YOU'LL NEVER FEEL
QUITE THE SAME ♪
♪ WHEN YOU GET A WHIFF
OF MY HERSHEY STAINS ♪
♪ I WANNA POOP
ON YOU TOO ♪
♪ I WANT TO
PEE IN YOUR FOOD ♪
♪ ONLY THING TO
MAKE MY LIFE COMPLETE ♪
♪ IS WHEN I TURN YOUR FACE
INTO A TOILET SEAT ♪
♪ I WANT TO PEE ON YOU ♪
♪ YES, I DO
YES, I DO ♪
♪ I'LL PEE ON YOU
I'LL PISS ON YOU ♪
♪ HATERS WANNA HATE
LOVERS WANNA LOVE ♪
♪ I DON'T EVEN WANT
NONE OF THE ABOVE ♪
♪ I WANT TO PISS ON YOU
YES, I DO ♪
♪ I'LL PISS ON YOU
I'LL PEE ON YOU ♪
♪ WON'T YOU BRAID
MY HAIR ♪
♪ SAY, WON'T YOU
BRAID MY HAIR ♪
♪ BEFORE YOU START
I'M GONNA FART ♪
♪ I'M GONNA FART ON YOU ♪♪
( applause and cheers )